another russia bombshell exploding in
the media's face here's what MSNBC's
Lawrence O'Donnell said about president
Trump's finances on his show last night
this is a single source okay who has
told me that the Deutsche Bank obtained
tax returns which they do have of Donald
Trump's show that the president pays
very little income tax this single
source close to Deutsche Bank has told
me that the Trump Donald Trump's long
documents their show that he has
co-signers that's how he was able to
obtain those loans and that the
co-signers are Russian oligarchs but
really that would explain it seems to me
every kind word Donald Trump has ever
said about Russia and Vladimir Putin if
true and I stress the if true Wow Rachel
Maddow space I think said it all but
after being ridiculed about his flimsy
reporting including by his own
co-workers at MSNBC O'Donnell tweeting
last night I made an error in judgment
by reporting an item about the
president's finances that didn't go
through our rigorous verification and
standards process I shouldn't have
reported it and I was wrong to discuss
it on the air I will address the issue
on my show tonight so Dana where is this
well first of all I don't think people
need to watch his show tonight okay
because one he's already shown that he
doesn't care about giving accurate
information I always say this on Twitter
too if you have to write big if true on
something that you're retweeting like
don't tweet it just wait and see if it
is actually true borings would be why
you watch the fire I understand that
mistakes can happen you could go to air
with something that isn't quite but he
walks all the way up to the line and he
has Rachel Maddow just waiting like what
really this huh it reminded me when she
said she had the president's tax returns
and you sat there for 20 minutes like
waiting for her to get to the pill he
did that for like two years we did that
yeah now
because the Russia story is one that
fizzled in April and they're trying to
figure out figure out a way to bring it
back but if you're gonna do that you
better be ready because now what happens
now President Trump can turn around and
say here they go again I told you and
he's proven they are proving his point
over and over again is it really a
mistake I mean when you say further and
you meant to say farther is this like
I'm it's hard for me to judge because I
have never made a mistake on this show I
think I'm batting a thousand and yeah
you know it's really good and it's the
ball am i the umpire yes but you would
think that MSNBC would be a little leery
of any Russian bombshell story they'd
just bet everything they'd put
everything on red for three years and
they lost the house so maybe no maybe
here's the theory maybe he got pranked
by he said a single-source that could
have been Trump on the phone with his
hand over the magazine yes it was
Russian oligarchs Russian all your trust
Rihanna's Larry
trust me trust me it could be that but I
mean it's it's you know it reminds me of
it reminds me of that thing on Twitter
that used to drive me crazy the
tick-tick-tick I remember like everybody
promising a bombshell oh it's coming up
today Oh better you better watch the new
it's all gonna come apart and it's just
people but viewers viewers must get
exhausted being promised bombshell after
bombshell we don't promise bombshells
here we just promise good healthy clean
fun what's your take one well I I'm
listening and I'm thinking to myself
it's so interesting it seems to me we've
gone away from gatekeepers in journalism
you know because social media is like
who has it first and who can just make
an outrageous statement that gets lots
of clicks and this was an outrageous
statement I mean by his own admission he
really didn't have the story as no
journalists in America would say a
single source and that you haven't gone
to your editors and nobody has vetted
this story to say well you know what do
we have from other people not nothing
like that he just makes the statement so
he got it wrong now that it's
interesting in saying that he made an
error in reporting this he's not saying
that the story is wrong he's saying he
was wrong and I so again to me it comes
back to social media were
people have what I call confirmation
bias in other words they they take
stories that they want to be true and
then they say oh you know what I'm gonna
believe this story and I'm not I'm not
gonna check it out because that might
get in the way of my good feeling so I'm
just going to report it and to me that
ends up with egg on your face
it's just bad journalism it's not the
way you do it but I see in this era with
the internet dominating everything this
is the way we're going and people don't
seem to understand this is a mistake
it's not good well and that's the point
that Trump's attorney made right which
is basically that when you go off of a
single source it's reckless and it's
verifiable those records were publicly
online Trump is the only guarantor so he
basically said look because it was so
reckless and because you ignored any
type of verification that was out there
and subsequent sources and this rises to
that level of actual malice and this has
other repercussions too right like we
know the house services financial
committee is investigating Trump is
investigating Deutsche Bank they are
laying off 18,000 workers in the next
couple years they're being federally
investigated for other reasons too so
when we start bringing in other entities
from these reckless comments and
assertions it's a ripple effect and so
yes journalists have to be much more
aware and and in ownership of what they
put out there it's not just a oh my bad
I retract
there's real-world consequences and even
even if he were to say to us Emily you
know he's not a journalist because I
think sometimes opinion people say oh
I'm not a journalist I just is my
opinion but he didn't present it as his
opinion right as a journalist I'm
disgusted by what happened how many
times have you read a story and there's
nobody who's cited in this story yeah
all anonymous sources a single-syllable
you make a mistake the worst thing
though the worst thing is the stories
that every both sides are doing this by
the way so-and-so is outraged sparks
outrage and what they use is tweets like
they find three tweets and that's the
story and that's all the outrage that's
all the outrage and it's like it's like
and then that generates another story
and then that generates another story
and it's a spiral and it's like and you
get down to it and there's nothing there
and what a waste of time and anger I
might say it's so interesting to me
though that Don
Trump has his lawyer threatened lawrence
O'Donnell with defamation over this I
mean how often have you seen a story
from Donald Trump and you think hmm
what's the source on that where's the
evidence of that and he's never lied
wand never never not once not once
he's directionally true no because you
have a thousand batting average yes what
is batting a thousand and twenty oh
really yes it's like you know when you
get a plus plus yeah
extra points for and get a 5.0 yeah
that's it makes no sense sure Emily got
a 5.0